bonsoir à vous à l'excès poulain merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
comment vous vous accueillez cette
décision du conseil d'état qui a donc
rejeté à la demande de reprise urgente
des cours en présentiel dans les
universités c'est dans la ligne directe
des mesures choisies par le gouvernement
toujours choisir le sacrifice de la
jeune génération l'empêché de vivre avec
ces mesures c'est couvre-feu à 20 heures
c'est fait interdite
et puis maintenant ces universités
déserté alors que les lieux de culte ont
ouvert à 30 personnes et là on ne
comprend pas alors qu'il y avait une
demande
les jeunes la jeunesse les jeunes éclaté
sont les grands oubliés de ce
quinquennat et les grandes victimes
cette crise on l'a vu un sur la
précarité dans laquelle ils sont poussés
puisqu'il n'y a plus de job étudiant le
nombre d'entre eux qui ont recours à des
banques alimentaires qui explosent mais
aussi la solitude dont ils souffrent
puisqu'ils ne peuvent pas se retrouver
avec des facultés ou ailleurs avec
d'autres amis notamment pour les
étudiants étrangers mais aussi des
étudiants qui sont dans des villes seul
loin de leurs familles c'est terrible
psychologiquement c'est terrible aussi
pour l'éducation
c'est tout ça est écrit dans le projet
porté par monsieur schwab des instances
de davos le grétry cette idée que la
digitalisation la numérisation de tous
les services y compris l'éducation et
bien été la solution à tous nos
problèmes qu'il fallait finalement
oublié le monde physique tel qu'il était
avant je crois qu'il faut refuser ce
monde là il est extrêmement dangereux et
un pays un continent qui sacrifie sa
jeunesse n'a aucun avenir et c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que les
jeunes sont simplement des sacrifiés à
la fois pour la dette qu'on est en train
d'accumuler qu'ils seront obligés de
rembourser si jamais les responsables
comme suivi le roi de gueule
madame lagarde sont toujours aux
manettes dans quelques années mais aussi
sur cette façon de se sociabiliser
devenu impossible
devenue dangereuse avec la phobie
finalement de l'autre avec cette
distanciation sociale parce que ce virus
qui n'est pas dangereux pour la grande
majorité des jeunes
eh bien il
il est dangereux pour la société on a
mis à l'arrêt parce qu'on est évidemment
il est dangereux de virus n'est vraiment
et aucune mesure n'est décidé en faveur
en direction des plus jeunes qui eux
sont vraiment ceux qui souffrent le plus
de cette crise et pourtant elle explique
poulain on se souvient des propos
d'emmanuel mâcon en verre justement
cette jeunesse qui était en première
ligne dans cette crise sanitaire
oui il a souvent des propos mais qui
sont rarement suivies d'actes et puis il
ya cette façon de gérer la crise oc qui
pose question où on apprend qu'ils
menaient le mâcon était pour un
déconfinement le 15 mai que finalement
lors d'un dîner avec jean castex après
le conseil de défense et bien on a
décidé de prendre la ligne dure celle de
jean castex donc cette mise en scène y
du gentil flic mauvais flic avec
finalement une disparition totale de la
démocratie et des instances
représentatives le pays aujourd'hui est
gouvernée par un conseil de défense par
des dîners privés entre des gens qui
écoutent plus ou moins des avis de
scientifiques qu'on ne connaît pas
forcément pour finalement décider du
sort de millions de personnes et les
députés n'ont aucun mot à dire les
sénateurs n'ont aucun mot à dire sauf à
faire des rapports a posteriori sur
cette gestion calamiteuse totalement
ubuesque 1 rappelons que la presse
étrangère par led absurdistan
autoritaire en ce qui concerne ce
quinquennat et ce moment que nous vivons
avec la crise comment peut-on tolérer
cela
je crois que le ras-le-bol est totale
dans les populations mais la souffrance
des plus jeunes et des étudiants est
réel et et elle n'est pas à minimiser
bien sûr que tout le monde est conscient
de l'importance de se confiner d'avoir
des gestes-barrières d'éviter la
propagation massive de virus pour éviter
l'engorgement des services d'urgence
mais enfin l'enseignement à distance
n'est pas une solution de long terme
c'est extrêmement difficile de
sociabiliser de faire court même à
distance de dégoûté d'avoir l'attention
nécessaire et puis tout simplement de
réfléchir on a besoin de ce contact
physique on a besoin d'eux des changes
est naturellement comme on le faisait
auparavant et avec des mesures barrières
qui seraient imposées dans les
universités je vois pas où serait le
problème à partir du moment où on
respecterait ses gestes là tout le monde
est très conscient de dire
responsabilité mais là on est en train
de plonger des générations dans une
précarité longue parce que au-delà des
études difficiles c'est l'accès à
l'emploi qui va être rendue impossible
avec l'absence des petits boulots et
puis une situation économique
catastrophique pour le continent
européen et aussi la question du droit à
l'éducation qui est mise en avant par
les enseignants après cette décision du
conseil d'état vrai vous entendre là
dessus et est également sur le conseil
d'état puisque aujourd'hui ce conseil
d'état a confirmé également la fermeture
à des remontées mécaniques à noël dans
les stations de ski donc le conseil
d'état qui va dans le sens de l'exécutif
oui clairement les ordres ont été donnés
de serrer la vis un puisqu'on voit
partout sur le continent les pays ont
décidé de serrer la vis pas c'est pas le
cas en espagne ou des stations de ski
vont rouvrir à la frontière avec la
france n'est pas le cas en suisse est
pas le cas en autriche mais c'est le cas
en bavière par exemple donc on se calque
un peu sur l'allemagne pour dire qu'on
va essayer de faire pareil mais on voit
aussi des pays du nord comme le danemark
comme la suite qui ont décidé d'avoir
des mesures plus coercitives ce qu'ils
n'avaient pas jusqu'à présent donc la
france qui se targue d'un bilan
exceptionnel dans les bilans les plus
calamiteux du monde vient décide de
suivre cette poussée restrictive qu'on
connaît depuis le début
sachant que ce deuxième confinement n'a
pas été un vrai confinement sauf pour
encore une fois les plus jeunes qui en
ont souffert avec la fermeture des bars
avec la livraison qui étaient interdites
à certaines heures donc même les petits
boulots dans la restauration qui n'ont
plus lieu d'être
et puis cette absence cefac vide rendez
vous compte la faculté l'université le
monde de la recherche le manque
d'éducation c'est là où on prépare le
futur
on est en train tout simplement de
saborder notre futur et de manière
volontaire pour protéger les plus âgés
certes c'est louable mais il faut quand
on parle du vaccin parler du bénéfice
risque est bien là il comme on ne peut
pas discuter dans les instances de
représentation que sont le sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale on ne réfléchit
pas au bénéfice risque de faire ce choix
de sacrifier les plus jeunes générations
or il est pour moi une catastrophe
particulièrement grave dans le cas de la
france dans le cadre des pays
vieillissant que sont les sociétés
européennes
merci beaucoup à vous alexis poulain
éditorialistes merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous